china says it will quote not renounce
the use of force against taiwan to
achieve reunification the warning comes
in a white paper on taiwan
that china issued on wednesday
it rounds off a week of the largest ever
chinese military exercises around taiwan
they came in response to u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi's visit to the
island last week
taiwan responded to the chinese drills
with exercises of its own
and a warning from the island's foreign
minister that china wanted to control
large swathes of the western pacific
so where does that leave relations
between china and taiwan to help us
answer that i'm joined in the studio by
taiwan's representative to germany
mr welcome a week of tit-for-tat
military exercises later where are we
with ties between china and taiwan the
thais leaks here on my neck
they tried to strangle us and we didn't
give up our freedom and if i think after
the tension of launching the rockets
into the oceans around salon taiwan and
the waterfront has also given china a
rocket and i think we can start it again
yeah but then it doesn't matter how many
rockets you fire china will always out
fire taiwan do you think the level of
tension between china and taiwan has
increased now sure it is but we are not
standing alone there we are one of the
allies the so-called indo-pacific
strategic alliance
we need us we need japan we need
uk france and germany but also we are
needed by all these countries because we
are very we are holding a very key role
playing the key role in the indo-pacific
strategic alliance we are we have a very
good microchip industry we have
democracy so we need them and they need
us so they cannot erode the taiwan
become under the control of china all
right the chinese military has also
warned court that it will continue to
carry out military training and prepare
for war what happens if china tomorrow
decides to blockade taiwan then all the
semiconductor industry that you're
talking about gets blockaded what
happens then yes that means that we're
not the only one country who
suffered under this this this blockade
german usa all the world all with who
needs uh microsoft they wouldn't have to
trip there would suffer under that so
that wouldn't let that happen are you
certain that the world will come to
taiwan's aid if taiwan is actually
threatened by china for an actual
invasion i has been asked
very often this kind of questions like
which americans who come over to help us
my answer is always no they won't come
because they are already there if you
take a look at close glance at that what
means the last two years that the u.s
navy the japanese australia they are
already there so we are not alone of
course we have to get prepared for
anything like
what happened in the last two weeks i do
want to talk to you about that but let's
talk about the preparations first uh
where is taiwan now is taiwan in a place
in which it needs to prepare
economically and militarily and faster
for a potential chinese invasion
i think yes we
well
as
like an old roman prophet said
if you want to have your freedom you
have to be prepared to fight for your
for your for your peace and freedom and
that's what we've been doing unless in
the last years
maybe in the last decade you have been
doing that but do you not think that the
the intensity of that has to increase
and the frequency with which you do that
has to increase so there is more of a
pressure on taiwan is there not after
these recent tensions it is i have to
admit it is
but
we want
that's not the reason why we give up our
freedom democracy there's always of
course there's always a risk we are we
know
and but we are sitting in assemble
together
with americans with all the friends
around the world we are sitting in the
boat and nobody rocks the ball right
okay
we'll talk about that but i would like
to talk about the people of taiwan
because everything that you're saying
increases the risk for the people of
taiwan as to what might befall them in
the event of an invasion and as we saw
and i'd like to show to our viewers a
report that a colleague of ours zachary
lee filed from taiwan as to how the
current round of military exercises
impacted the people of taiwan
these bomb shelters in the insurance
house had been a storeroom for years
but now she is preparing to use it again
the chinese military drills near taiwan
have made war seem like a real
possibility to her
we need to clean it up first so we can
have a place to hide if a war breaks out
it's safer to stay in here you can see
it as a solidly built shelter
this small bomb shelter was built nearly
a hundred years ago
during the second world war
she never expected to need it one day
she is not alone the increased military
activity has raised concerns here in
southern taiwan
residents living nearly air base are
very used to the sounds of fighter
aircrafts by the past few days let's say
dozens more fighter jets are taking off
and landing even at midnight and this
has raised worries here
sharon is one of them
following the news about the chinese
studios has become a part of his daily
routine
he has even asked his local
administrator where the air race
shelters are
we are used to chinese intimidation
it's been going on for decades
but this time the drills are much closer
to us
this of course has us worried
in taiwan concerns about military crisis
are slowly rising
a local survey found that a third of the
taiwanese are worried about possible
conflict with china
some are even seeking medical help to
deal with their anxiety
psychiatrist yan chong chai says his
passions have increased by nearly 30
percent
one of my patients has experienced war
and he feels stressed when he sees
reports about the drills or the war in
ukraine
others across the island however have
taken the tensions in their stride
young finds that many here are numbed to
chinese threats
but a further escalation he says could
quickly upset that balance
mr is still with us the taiwanese
representative to germany you saw that
report by my colleague zachary lee there
mr chair all this began after nancy
pelosi's visit to taiwan
did that visit make taiwan safer
that recalls me
a new friend i met the other days on the
street he introduced himself to me by
saying hello i'm unafraid of germany and
i say i'm afraid of china
yes the strategy attacks of china is
threatening some of us
but
it's worthy it's worthy that pelosi make
this visit and we welcome him from the
bottom of heart because it was a sign of
symbol the sign of
solidarity but you've had those uh
similar signs before i mean my question
to you is what does taiwan know now
after nancy pelosi's visit about u.s
commitment to taiwan that it didn't know
earlier
the accretion of china has had already
already been there before the visit of
the pelosi maybe people here didn't know
that much but we experienced that that's
the reason why pelosi said i came here i
made this visit because i want to
support our friends in a democracy
who asks the understanding of china so
it's not the question it's not so
correct i would say yes we have known
the equation of china and the china has
still there real fast but you just
admitted earlier that the intensity of
chinese military drills and the
intensity of chinese belligerence has
increased after this visit i'm just
trying to understand how that helps
taiwan
that makes us uh that keeps us
bring us into the awareness of the real
fields of china and i think it's good
that we know
that they're territorials they are going
to attack us i have known that most of
people the communists have known that
since the tiananmen 1989 on the first of
july june we know they were killed
their people they will attack taiwan if
they think it's necessary because
they are straightly with us with
military and we are strengthened with
our democracy so just to be clear you
think that uh chinese invasion
of taiwan it is not a question
of if but when yeah
clearly in the last 10 years the chinese
the chinese government has shown their
real affairs not only toward taiwan but
also toward japan and also especially in
the south china sea that's the reason
why there is this concept
indo-pacific strategic alliance no more
asia-pacific right so and a chinese
attempt to invade taiwan to reunify with
the mainland will succeed or will it not
succeed no
no and this will not succeed because you
have the indo-pacific around you we have
we have
our own
military we are working very closely
with the french neighborhood in within
every country but the u.s hasn't
committed that it will commit u.s troops
to fight uh on the side of taiwan they
don't have two
that's the policy of ambiguity
and what they have what if they don't
come through and if taiwan is left alone
to face china we have to face that
will you win right i will
if you lose china outguns your outmans
you they're going they're going to pay a
big price so big that they will think it
again
it is worth it to attack taiwan and
in case they want to unify us or reunify
us whatever you say they should try to
attract us not attack us but then china
is not listening to these demands is it
you're right but
let's see i think
it's like it's a chicken games
we want anyway because we had met we
have met the development front from the
dictators dictatorship to a democracy so
the freedom we have the freedom of
speech freedom of religion and so on
democracy we will keep it up let me just
ask you a direct question if you can
answer that briefly
if the us does not deploy u.s troops in
assistance for taiwan in the event of a
chinese attack can taiwan hope to beat
china back
well in this case i'm not sure
and to be realistic to be honest we have
to see but anyway we won't give it up
we won't get just like below pelosi she
was threatened she was threatened so
badly and she didn't get up and what
happened she visited then she left the
taiwan safety
and
china launched the record and they come
back to the normal life and i think we
did a good decision we'll leave it there
thank you so much for coming in mr
xichiway taiwan representative to
germany and that's all we have time for
you